I am going to admit to you this next
story is a little bit confusing
the story is about a Montana Republican
lawmaker who seemingly suggested during
a floor speech that she'd rather her
daughter kill herself than transition to
being a trans male now the confusing
part of this is we don't know whether
This Woman's daughter actually is trans
or has expressed uh symptoms of gender
dysphoria we we just don't know because
the clip is confusing this is state
representative from Montana Carrie
seekins Crow doesn't say her daughter is
trans but says her daughter is or was
suicidal for three years and that she
would rather her daughter be suicidal
than
um do the emotional manipulation that I
guess she considers claiming to feel as
though you're
a different gender would be in her mind
it's definitely disgusting it's
obviously uh the type of thing someone
who shouldn't be a parent says but it is
a little bit confusing let's listen one
of the big issues that we have heard
today and we've talked about lately is
that that without surgery the risk of
suicide goes way up
well I am one of those parents
who lived with a daughter who was
suicidal for three years
okay
someone once asked me wouldn't I just do
anything to help save her
and I really had to think the answer was
no and the answer was
no there you go I was not going to give
in to her emotional manipulation because
she was incapable of making those
decisions and I had to make those
decisions for her I was not going to let
her tear apart my family and I was not
going to let her tear apart me because I
had to be strong for I had to have a
vision for her life when she had none
was incapable of having none so she
doesn't straight up say my daughter
expressed that she's trans
but she said it was an emotional
manipulation
and if your child is suicidal and you
call it an emotional manipulation
whether they're trans or not
that's really something else and
remember these are the folks who want to
decide who should and shouldn't be
parenting children right these are the
same folks who then will say you know I
don't think a gay couple should adopt
shouldn't or shouldn't be able to you
know uh work with a surrogate or
whatever these are the folks who want to
tell everybody else how you shouldn't
who should and shouldn't be allowed to
parent this is like Westboro Baptist
Church level stuff there is something
called narcissistic parenting and you
can Google this and read a lot about it
when a narcissist focuses their lack of
empathy and their delusions of grandeur
towards their child that's narcissistic
parenting and sometimes narcissistic
parents view their child as an extension
of themselves of themselves so therefore
they say well the child exists for my
needs and therefore I'm going to say
something like oh you're suicidal oh
you're saying that you're trans that's
an emotional manipulation I'm going to
decide for you this that the other thing
based on what I think is best for me
right now
whatever the full details of this story
are
a disgusting woman who no doubt claims
to have the Moral Majority